[Música]
ya lo decíamos hoy en directo a vamos a
Santiago la capital de Chile esto luego
de que la Corte Internacional de
Justicia de la haya fallara sobre la
disputa que mantenía este país con
Bolivia por las aguas del Río silala el
tribunal determinó que las aguas del
cielo son manantiales que nacen en
Bolivia pero también son un curso
internacional que fluye hacia chile para
ampliar esta información conectamos con
Patricia Luna ellas corresponsal de
France 24 en Chile Patricia surgen
muchas dudas por ejemplo Cómo nació esta
disputa y que era lo que pedía cada país
así es Es una disputa de larga Data que
con esta sentencia se cierra de forma
definitiva es un fallo inapelable y
parte en 2016 cuando chile durante el
gobierno de Michelle bachelet decide
demandar a Bolivia ante las amenazas de
entonces Evo Morales para poder utilizar
el agua para que se declare como un
cauce internacional y por lo tanto poder
estar el agua que
atraviesa el territorio la frontera en
la parte chilena en el 2018 Bolivia
realiza una contrademanda argumentando
que ha construido una serie de canales y
que hay una parte un agua artificial que
está aprovechando chile y que no debería
utilizar el fallo ha sido un fallo en el
que se reconoce el cauce Internacional
del río y que también satisface las
demandas de ambas partes deja
satisfechos un poco a ambos al también
de forma muy categórica señalar que como
las partes ya habían acordado sí es un
caucedo internacional pero rechazar de
un lado la demanda por parte de Chile de
que Bolivia no había cooperado y también
deja satisfecha de esta forma a Bolivia
bueno y justamente usted lo estaba
mencionando el pronunciamiento del
tribunal dejó satisfecho al presidente
Gabriel boric que celebró la decisión
pero posteriormente su homólogo
boliviano Luis Arce también se mostró de
acuerdo Entonces por qué no habían
cancelado este proceso
bueno el propio el propio dictamen de
tribunal Establece que ambos en el
proceso del juicio que fue muy largo
ambas partes habían reconocido que el
río era un cauce internacional y que
hasta el punto de que era un poco
redundante este fallo pero desde chile
sí que se quería garantizar y tener una
certeza jurídica en firme para lo que
pueda ocurrir en el futuro esto es un
poco lo que se establece de hecho el
presidente borich afirma que hemos
acudido a la corte a buscar la certeza
jurídica que hemos obtenido y también
remarca que es un fallo inapelable es
decir que Aquí se termina todo y por
otro lado también recalcó en su
declaración al conocerse el fallo que
chile no tiene que compensar
económicamente a Bolivia por el uso del
agua